welcome to this video playing a VC 1964
okay let's see Kings Indian and to the
classical it son classical is by far the
most popular line I'm always surprised
the damn this is even the case on an
amateur level where would think that
people don't like to get like King at
ekta all the time okay but you play
tonight d to 992 which is a very decent
alternative and most of the time with
this line you don't turn get your king
attacked so one so viciously we are
plagued with a five and c5 this is quite
a solid set up for black some not the
most ambitious one but quite reliable
and now Kim at one point I need to play
a five normally why it's idea with this
line is some not to play f3 interesting
Bishop see tuned
okay okay let's put it put it on age 6
Bishop c2 was an interesting move maybe
is even intending to play Bishop a form
yep in fact he is if I take yeah I'm not
so sure what down the night on a4ai mean
okay yeah the night on a for potentially
am can go to be six but not sure about
all that okay let's get rid of this
special this is maybe a debatable
decision yeah originally I thought I
take on e4 but Bishop g5 and push on
page six I don't know it did look
strange the others this might be an
might be quite good for wide Wow well
this I didn't expect not not so sure
what what the great point about the
night on b6 here rook dat could have
played Bishop a five but ok this is not
possible now obviously interesting so
rook b6 is playing Bishop f5
interesting still the night doesn't have
many squares if I go here strongly
having this check here no he's some he
also needs to very about the e4 pawn
this pawn I'm attacking
I don't know this looks very strange for
me very strange to me the night with no
return on b6 isn't there some way to
take use of that
at the moment I don't see it which is
probably mostly due to my own stupidity
I mean he didn't player 3 I don't
understand anything f3 her I didn t
player 3 and what's not beehive all
about preparing Bishop f5 on hmm
yeah okay it's a central point and I'm
going to take it what now we should be
fine
Bishop f5 i also have an ID g5 attacking
the Queen and if I take on a 50 k 5
route 85 Queen B 6 queeny's haven't
check look f7 Queen a seven others so it
saves himself but if I play night g5
first taking the Queen let's do that not
spending so much time that I'm going to
not make it at the end and now rook
takes a five come on let's just let's
just play that at the end there's still
this is God root B 5 which are
completely forgot about
that's bad Wow I completely forgot about
b5 and I have no place for the Queen
what the heck no and his God look a 7 on
top of all of that so I don't have I
don't really and I cannot really play
night at five or something [ __ ] sorry
how unnecessary is that
yeah Wow the position was probably
winning in so many ways and they found
one found a way to to really lose it
bread okay I want to cover rugby seven
it's mean it's probably not one hundred
percent clear maybe maybe I can do
something with Queen a 28 XC 4 and the
night on f5 is a very good piece that
covers d6 and many crucial squares and
okay if he goes rook ph is some he's got
him he's got at least a big check coming
and I was going to play what piece am
now
ah what the frustrating game really
check
Queen g5 medium have no way to prevent
that unbelievable I already acted this
committed complete suicide here yeah no
way to time Morgan prevented black
resigned wow they are not winning this
is really a bit frustrating you have can
you can ESO as I as I already suspected
this minus 3 this position like and we
can win in many ways okay I took here
which is not the best computer wants to
play rookie aid yeah this is much
stronger it's always so simple if you
look at it afterwards who cared yeah
it's still hanging on e4 and like you
I'm threatening all this discovered text
the Queen needs to move here and after
that i'm just taking and this is this is
just just over with this threat coming
this is completely lost and this is PRS
is also winning but not 95 on a g5 also
wins I just need to play Knight f5 here
just night at 5am and then in tomah this
piece has nowhere to go and threatening
grew k5 and you cannot prevent any other
yeah well i played this because i forgot
about Luke b5 and this is this is still
playable probably but I need to to play
differently we form before I still the
game but I boobed with this I overlooked
to be seven I just only thought about
Luke be age and Joe it's um it's a
checkmate so this was really bad
well alright thanks for watching